what you want to hear a rap about tax
evasion yeah the whitest thing possible
just is the acceptable prime isn't it
it's the acceptable crime tax evasion I
like it and we're in Hermosa I love you
know I'm talking about as beachfront
properties don't come cheap when you're
paying it properly but tax evasion guys
over here this quarter what are you
gonna hit us with calculus I wish you
hadn't said that I've had three drinks
and it's gonna be difficult but that's
okay it's something to do with math
isn't it
Matthew call it math not maths that's
weird math calculus and tax evasion guys
here what you want to write about
lactose thank you nice lactose tax
evasion and a calculus
hopefully we'll forget these guys over
here what's it gonna be non-newtonian
fluids oh boy you are a mean ol bunch
tonight non-newtonian fluids laugh
expects calculus and tax evasion when
you say tax evasion I was like well
that'll be the hardest one so far
No
all right let's not only look stupid and
ask them you sir the man who is laughing
at my children you're my favorite person
here tonight and I hope you gonna be my
Savior what would you like a rap about
police officers you look quite buff for
you a police officer okay I'll play it
nice then there's not many positive raps
about police officers don't have you've
heard them be friends with the police
coming straight from the underground huh
that's a famous one okay gosh this I
wish I could walk off stage right now
tax evasion calculus lactose
non-newtonian fluids and police officers
okay
this then lovely people of the mouth of
each comedy magic club to close out the
show to give you a real Big Finish it's
gonna be a little thing called a
freestyle rap that is a rap made up on a
spot based entirely on those suggestions
and do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously toe-curling Lee
embarrassingly bad as you're expecting
it to be it's a sound of two hundred
people being wholly unconvinced so you
drop that
I'm excited if I say anything mean
please don't hurt me
[Music]
I've got the knowledge I don't lack
those never eat milk or cheese that the
left toes in my belly makes it grow
mixes well beats me pop out the gas on
my back wants to smell when I be in that
cheese I be puffing out breathe if you
see me in the dairy aisle say please
crisp you need to take the pill before
you swallow otherwise and lactose coming
out tomorrow I don't like toes cuz I got
10 here a funny little pun in school I
feel all my teachers say there's nothing
better than getting calculus yeah
there's nothing lesser there is nothing
you can teach me or catch you later
I do that math on the calculator why do
I need to know what X is or even wide oh
yeah right check this results here I'll
add together integers DX by dy era going
into death one person turn into the
person beside them and saying Gary's
wise king like Poseidon I get a lot of
money I've gotta lure choices never pay
the government the tax avoidance is the
main way that I make that profit the
government wants it but I keep it in my
pocket send it off away yeah stay from
them
I've been me as yours I'm in the cavemen
near or far I'm in Panama layer you can
check my accounts in the Panama papers
they employ people to hunt you down
they're like that IRS from town to town
back in the day if the comfort of his
home
tax evasion how they caught Al Capone
they were like year Chris police at the
door knocking with the tommy guns then
they saw Al and his gangsters sitting on
the sofa busted down the door II had no
hope bare but they didn't shoot him they
would rather though he was still the
king ruling police in Chicago bring it
today
gara gara respect you so I'll just rhyme
cement like Police Interceptor
it's the sound of the police I'm really
scared off the leash God be careful a
wink I'm so flirty please don't put me
overdoing the poverty Gera week slowly
for the glove box toes on my feet yet
God no stocks last thing you know I'm
going to do it
custard cornflour non-newtonian fluids
they Island it quits until you apply
force if you put your pouf down like a
very wise horse then they apply the
equal force back yeah you've got the
knowledge of the fluids I would like but
I don't and he's clapping so it means
I'm right you're trying to mess with me
hitting my brain is shite now Oh God
let's bring it to a close even though
the easy is one there was left toes
[Applause]
that's the sound of 200 anuses
unclenching you guys have fun thanks for
that to get myself a because that was
good
thank God thank God if it would gone
badly just sprinkle cocaine on me now be
awful